hallo herzmittel tenniswelt heute ist 12
und verbaue reihe im letzten video haben
wir ja verkündet dass wir bauen werden
und so kam auch wirklich sehr gut für
euch an und auch wir bekommen sehr viel
positives feedback und ganz viele tipps
und tricks auch von euch ja schon ganz
viele e mails bekommen
felhi beachtet beim bau dies oder das
finde ich auch weiterhin sehr gut denn
man kann eigentlich nie genug erfahrung
bekommen wir haben uns auch natürlich im
freundeskreis immer umgehört und es gibt
immer jemanden oder was heißt jeder der
baut hat irgendetwas im nachhinein
anders machen würde und davon kann man
natürlich profitieren und einfach den
anderen mit geben
ich hab das spiel eine e-mail bekommen
wir werden ja mit meinen eltern zusammen
ziehen die komplexe uns ins haus und
dass man einfach ein behindertengerecht
baut altersgerecht baut weil wenn man
jetzt baut dort baut man ja wirklich für
die nächsten 30 jahre und nicht nur für
heute
vorausschauend bauen genau das sieht
wieder im auto dass man sagt okay fand
auch nicht fünf jahre genau nächsten tag
genau und wir haben sich schon überlegt
wir bauen wir haben um euch das ein
bisschen erklärt und gezeigt warum wir
aufbauen was die beweggründe waren da
könnt ihr euch gern das video dazu
anschauen und nachdem man sich überlegt
hat ob man bauen möchte oder auch man
auch etwas vorhandenes kaufen möchte und
umbauen möchte muss man sich natürlich
überlegen wie viel ein echtes ganze und
deswegen habe ich heute ein paar tipps
und tricks hier im video für euch und
einfach ein paar dinge die ihr
vielleicht beachten solltet bevor ihr
überhaupt mit dem gedanken spielen zu
bauen
moratti nicht wir sind dieses jahr seit
neun jahren verheiratet wäre es
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile schon jeder
vorrath mittlerweile auch und wir haben
vor etwa sieben jahren und
bausparvertrag abgeschlossen
er war damals ich glaube zu drei prozent
also 3 prozent hat genau den aufwand für
vertrag ist so auf sich hat sich
faktisch die zinsen zu dem derzeitigen
zeitraum und kann doch eben im monat
immer irgendwas weglegen ich war damals
studentin hofmann noch in der ausbildung
und es heißt wir haben wir 40 bis 50
euro weg gelegt als wir dann weiter
gearbeitet haben mehr weg gelegt das
heißt man kann das auch immer wieder
anpassen und aufstocken und so haben wir
in den letzten sieben jahren einfach ein
bisschen geld angespart und nach den
vielen jahren läuft der bauspar kredit
aus dieser vertrag und man kann den
complete benutzen um zu bauen
weil es natürlich bei uns diesen
schwachsinn nicht denn wir haben damals
drei prozent sind platz gehabt und jetzt
sind die zinsen dass ich viel viel
günstiger das heißt wir lassen uns den
bausparvertrag also die die summe
einfach ausgefahren und benutzten diese
summe jetzt für den bau natürlich zu den
heutigen finden
momentan ist es wirklich so also ein
gutes bauen wenn sie zinsen sind günstig
und falls ihr jetzt gerade nicht bauen
wollt könnt ihr euch aber zum beispiel
ihren bausparvertrag abschließen und
dann eben sieben jahre später mit bienen
mit diesem finden bauen also die sind
beide keine versicherungsvertreter aber
für trockenes es sinnvoll heute oder
eben in dieser zeit jetzt auf
abzuschließen oder will man im rathaus
hat man sich wissen genau wann genau wie
man schon im haushalt und gar nicht mehr
bauen möchte kann man sich trotzdem wie
zinsen sichern und gleich in sieben bis
zehn jahren eben doch noch was machen ja
also geldes günstig baustoffe prag ist
wirklich sehr sinnvoll und
eigenleistungen eigenleistungen genommen
also bei uns zählt jetzt die summe die
wir jetzt angespannt schon als ein
eigenkapital aber ganz wichtig ist auch
meine freundin zum beispiel baut gerade
und die haben fast 80 prozent selber
gebaut weil der papa elektriker ist und
der bruder ist irgendwas anderes
das heißt ein ganz ganz viel
eigenleistung und das wird eben auch mit
angerechnet und somit brauchen wir nicht
so viel eigenkapital mit einbringen
gesund ist immer so um die 20 prozent
des bundes wenn man sagt eigenkapital
hat und dann ist es sinnvoll die zinsen
langfristig zu sichern also langfristig
zu finanzieren das man einfach eine
bessere lobby in dem film genau wenn der
punkt wichtig ist dann suchen wir
normalerweise nicht über 20 jahren als
bezahl welt so günstig wird momentan ich
glaube bei uns ist so also wir bauen
energetisch das heißt wir haben uns
natürlich sehr gut überlegt wir haben
uns vorher so ein energiepark geholt das
war auch bei uns sinnvoll weil der
einfach ausrechnen konnte wie viel
energie verbrauchen wir in diesem haus
und
von daher was brauchen wir an steinen
zum beispiel fenster benutzen wir da
haben wir seine genommen die man die
stemmen muss weil es einfach von sich
aus schon isoliert sind und wenn man
wirklich sehr energetisch und effizient
baut dann kann man einen kfw
förderkredite bekommen
das heißt man bekommt zum beispiel die
summe 100000 euro und muss dann aber nur
meine 1000 volt betragen 90 muss man
zurück getarnt im head to head mit 0 75
prozent es ist heiss theoretisch
aufgenommen bekommt aber geld dafür dass
keine zinsen mehr loszusagen und
energetisch aufgebaut und so besser ist
dieser weg hat er selbst hat bei 55 wir
wollen auf 5 und für genau das heißt wir
gucken jetzt was wir noch optimieren
können
dafür einfach noch bessere kritiken
bekommen und deswegen machen wir doch
unabhängig vom öl gas und eventuell
sogar schaffen vom strom ist natürlich
auch tragbar und so mancher team ist bei
der bank beantragen und macht die bank
für euch genau das ist mit ihrem
bankberater sprechen und davon wird
schon beim nächsten thema weiter einen
kredit aufnehmen möchte mit dir
natürlich zur bank gehen und da ist
natürlich sehr gut wenn ihr auch ein
bankberater gut kennt und wenn er
einfach eure finanzen so ein bisschen
den überblick hat und einfach weiß was
ihr tun müsst um was ihr tun könnt
bei uns war das auto erkennt mich ja
schon seit ewigkeiten und erkennt mein
papa und alle und was natürlich sehr
wichtig ist dass ich jetzt überlegt man
nimmt jetzt eine summe iks auf muss man
natürlich immer berücksichtigen dass man
ein bisschen davon abweichen kann können
einfach immer wieder probleme auftauchen
bei einem freund von uns war es zum
beispiel hat in der bachstraße gebaut
und für die ganze zeit gar nicht warum
die bachstraße heißt jedenfalls kam beim
grundstücks gutachten haus darf da unten
drunter malen bach vorbeiflog
und das ganze jetzt wie hainburg
moorgebiet war und er dürfte dann da
nicht drauf bauen sondern musste das
haus auf stelzen setzen
das ganze hatte dann über 60.000 euro
noch mal zusätzlich gekostet
will ich kraft genug hat kann
studiomusiker
für mich jedenfalls war das einfach so
eine summe die nicht mit eingerechnet
war beim hausbau aber die einfach
daneben noch mal zusätzlich mit
aufnehmen musste und auch bei uns sind
jetzt schon
weil sie dinge aufgetaucht wir haben zum
beispiel den statiker dann natürlich die
architektur abnehmen muss und das ganze
auf rechnet und da wir im gewerbegebiet
bauen und gewerblich bauen muss bei uns
auch entgegen staatlicher das ganze
prüfen das heißt plan ist auch nochmal
kosten die einfach zusätzlich mit dazu
kamen die wir einfach nicht
berücksichtigt haben aber nicht nur das
so auch andere fehler sind sonst
aufgetaucht und dafür fahren wie man es
kurz auf die baustelle hier zum beispiel
www.karate die war am anfang nur bis
dahin
und bitte nicht gedacht wenn jetzt bei
autoprint steht also papas auto in unser
auto die sind beide nicht vor großen
ganz normale autos aber dann wäre die
gerade im 50 schon so und durch die zwei
durchgänge die einfach zwei gebäude hier
verbindet hätten wir gar nicht mehr
durchgehen können
das heißt die garage musste jetzt hier
erweitert werden und das sind natürlich
auch im schritt was das statiker unter
gegen lotte garantiert noch mal abnehmen
muss hier unten im erdgeschoss haben wir
noch ein kleines problem gehabt um
fahrten wir hier eigentlich zwei
büroräume und eine toilette und dann
haben wir aber erst hier als die mauern
von eingezeichnete waren einfach
günstigen doch die bürger viel zu klein
waren das heißt damit aus zwei wagen in
einem raum gemacht das ist da hier
hinten und hielt es mit sehen jetzt
müssen sich alstom und frank und
beurteilen das ist aber ganz okay doch
die verstehen das ganz gut aber
jedenfalls muss das natürlich auch
wieder vom statiker und prüfstatiker
abgenommen werden das heißt wie vorhin
haben wir einfach baustopp dadurch dass
wichtig garage verändert hat und auch
die zwei räume hat sich natürlich die
komplette statik verändert werden den
eingang komplett umlegen müssen lässt
sich hinter mir
und deswegen haben wir eben den baustopp
missbrauch warten dass der statiker das
alles abnimmt dagegen statiker alles
abnimmt und dann kommt hoffentlich bald
weitergehen aber werden auch für einen
baustopp gehabt denn wir haben gerade
minusgrade und unter sechs grad kann man
hier einfach nicht arbeiten also sechs
grad ist das minimum
deswegen geht hoffentlich bald weitere
in das wetter wieder ein bisschen besser
wird aber einfach zu warten
er gerät auch wir haben planungsfehler
gemacht und mussten im 5 jetzt schon vom
jetzigen zeitpunkt offenbach steht nach
finanzieren das ist auch der nächste
punkt die nachfinanzierung demokrat muss
player sind schon noch mal zur bank
gehen und unseren kredit aufstocken
dafür später mit wackeligen knien wenn
ihr bei immer ganz gut den guten
kontakte und guten draht bauarbeiten
haben ganz einfach mal das fundament
gebaut und muss schon nach vier jahren
also irgendwie sind blöd aber das kann
passieren wenn ihr auch kosten wie
notarkosten und keine ahnung in welche
ämter die einfach noch mal geld wollen
weil du irgendwie nochmal was prüfen
muss eine wasserleitung legen muss wir
müssen zum beispiel fahrrad stellplätze
bauen
das wussten wir auch noch da mit dem
neuen fahrradstellplätze überdacht
gebaut werden weil wir alle im
gewerbegebiet sind und befinden hat die
auflagen und jede gemeinde hat da andere
auflagen
von daher kann da immer was und
verhaltet sehen uns auf euch zukommen
und deswegen ist immer ganz wichtig
einen kleinen puffer mit einzuplanen
genau also wirklich nicht vergessen die
bauern eben kurz mit einrechnet tag
kosten
wie gesagt dass mit den eltern und alles
und laibe brot ich bin als strafe noch
als klein gerechnet und ich waren bis
jetzt merkt vom verein für mich
schwäbisch-badischen als nächstes ist
natürlich auch ganz wichtig wir kennen
das von freunden die dann auf der
baustelle gern mal war ohne rechnung
machen lassen einfach schwarz machen
lassen und empfehlen wir euch absolut
nicht das ist immer ganz gut alle
effekte auf rechnung machen zu lassen
für beide seiten also überlegt euch mal
arbeiter steht auf der baustelle im
passiert irgendwas technik verzichtet
auf der baustelle oder überlegt mal
andersherum
da braucht euch etwas einen die
wasserrohre zum beispiel und irgendwann
nach ein paar monaten platzen die
wasserrohre und dann seid ihr nicht
sicher das heißt bei dem freund von uns
war es nämlich für die abwasserrohre
einbauen lassen und ein paar monate
später hat er im schaden gab von über
80.000 euro weil die einfach alle
aufgeplatzt findet das ganze paket
laminat alles war kaputt und zum glück
hatte er alles auf rechnung das heißt
die versicherung der firma hat alles
übernommen und von daher ist es nicht
empfehlenswert etwas ohne rechnung zu
machen auch wenn man gerne mal
vielleicht darauf zurückgreift aber das
kommt bei uns auf keinen fall in frage
und das empfehlen wir euch auch auf
jeden fall nicht
mit den leuten freunde auf den
bauarbeiten die versicherung der
arbeiten lassen sich arbeiten lassen
wollen und ist alles kostet mit ihnen
nicht rechnet und lauter kleine kleine
kleine dinger machen ist natürlich immer
noch fragen
ich denke dass ich hier in diesem video
ein paar tipps und tricks für euch hatte
vor allem wegen der finanzierung und was
ihr im prinzip im vornherein schon ein
bisschen beachten können
am montag gibt es ein video von der
baustelle heute war ich nur kurz dort
braucht man wirklich sehr sehr kalt ist
überverkauft ist ein bisschen motor
credit dann und auf der baustelle ist
werde den monat besuchen dass sie dir
mal was der monat den ganzen tag
arbeitet und nächste woche sonntag sind
wir auf der baumesse in münchen
da hat uns aber man sich auch schuldig
und samstags sonntags immer in köln am
samstag am 21
auf der baumesse in münchen in halle a2
doch immer am stand von keller und
keller hat uns da 200 karten für euch
zur verfügung gestellt die vom verlost
wurden ich freue mich auf meine
zuschauer vielleicht wird ja auch
zufällig auf der baumesse kommt und
frank gerne auf dem stand abzweigs el
alto besuchen
und ja ich freue mich schon drauf wie
sie schon freitagabend noch mal um genau
wie mein kleiner kinder da informieren
wir uns ein bisschen mein bruder ist mit
dabei und da laufen wir durch die messe
als nächste woche war viel unterwegs
aber es wird eine sehr spannende und
schöne woche und wie gesagt haltet am
montag einen tag gibt es das dritte
video von unserer baureihe nun also bis
montag und bis morgen morgen gibt's
einem normalen flut auf video gebannt zu